affichage meeting distribution de tracts
la campagne des élections
départementales prend sa vitesse de
croisière tout comme nos journaux de
campagne dont nous ouvrons tout de suite
un nouveau numéro
et c'est trop de départementale nous
conduit dans l'yonne ce soir eric pour
un groupement sur le canton de pont sur
yonne oui alors il est situé à l'extrême
nord du département il est d'abord la
particularité d'être à la fois rural et
à la limite de l'île de france ici le fn
réalise des scores très élevés et il
fait de ce canton l'un de ses objectifs
en face la droite et la gauche tente de
résister reportage de nathalie
d'affaires et christian d'érable ce
canton est l'un des objectifs
prioritaires du front national au point
de parachuter un conseiller de marine le
pen pour battre la campagne du nord de
l'yonne
bonjour madame enchantait julien houle
bonjour monsieur côté de l'épousé du
secrétaire départemental du fn
alexandrine ferron le jeune transfuge de
l'udc veut faire de ce canton un exemple
de la ruralité oublié on le voit lors de
nos réunions publiques on le voit lors
de nos rencontres ils ont envie d'une
alternative patriotes ils ont envie
d'une protection protection de la
ruralité protection de leur identité
protection de leur cadre de vie
protection qui et je dirai pas menacé
par par l'immigration par l'insécurité
arrivé en tête aux européennes est déjà
au second tour des cantonales de 2011
le fn espère ravir le siège du
socialiste dominique bourreau candidat à
un troisième mandat comme remède à la
désespérance le maire de villeneuve la
guyard
méthon avant son action pour attirer des
entreprises et est le passage son
adversaire frontiste
ce sont des gens hors sol qui viennent
s'implanter en nous parlant de ruralité
avec des petits mocassins et puis qui
font un rapport entre la région
parisienne des choses qui se passent à
pouilly-en-auxois donc qu'ils sont
complètement déconnectés du sol et de
ses problématiques et des problèmes que
rencontrent nos habitants la partie
s'annonce d'autant moins facile pour le
sortons que par rapport à 2011
il compte un adversaire supplémentaire
sur sa gauche bien décidé à ne pas lui
faire de cadeaux ce n est notre
principal
évidemment ennemis mais la droite aussi
parce que la droite dirige le conseil
général de l'yonne depuis 1970 ici dans
le canton nous avons dominique bourreau
au ps on pense que tous ces messieurs
sont quand même bien assis dans leur
siège depuis longtemps un contexte qui
pourrait bien faire les affaires de la
droite le binôme soutenu par l'ump élu d
y espère profiter d'un vote sanction du
gouvernement pour faire basculer ce
canton il doit toutefois se livrer à un
exercice d'équilibriste
il faut faire entendre que ce coin de
l'yonne est oubliée alors même que le
département est gérée par la droite
depuis plus de 40 ans auxerre c'est loin
la région encore plus et on a vraiment
une spécificité de notre territoire
qu'il faut faire reconnaître est portée
aux départements pour ne pas être oublié
que ce soit les routes que ce soit le
transport que ce soit à tous à tous
points de vue
il ya vraiment il faut vraiment porter
ce territoire un canton d oublier qu'il
suscite en tout cas bien des convoitises
et on reste dans l'yonne pour commencer
à passer quelques tweets en revue oui
avec un échange musclé entre deux
candidats du canton de sens 2 cela
commence par un tweet du socialiste
pascal simon qui se réjouit du succès de
l'avion solaire himpens ça c'est
l'aventuré crie-t-il ce qui lui vaut un
tacle du candidat fn jacques feliciano
qui le trouvent déconnecté ce qui a le
don d'agacer le premier qui lui
demandent d'arrêter ainsi de suite ça
continue sur une durée de riom 36 heures
et puisque l'on parle du fn le compte
twitter bleu marine de la nièvre se
réjouit de la défaite en justice de sos
racisme l'association avait porté
plainte contre le candidat et conseiller
municipal de nevers christophe gaillard
pour des propos qu'elle avait jugée à
caractère raciste mais cette claque a
été classée sans suite en saône et loire
serait ce le retour d'arnaud montebourg
à la retour via un tweet rapide pour
inviter à la lecture d'un article des
échos est pas étonnant puisque cet
article est intitulé la saône et loire
érigé en modèle de gestion etc il
souligne son désendettement grâce à
l'action d'un certain arnaud montebourg
et en côte d'or c'est le député ps
laurent grandguillaume qui s'implique
dans la campagne pourrait lui aussi a
tweeté ce matin pour inviter à la
mobilise
via son blog on entend ici ou là que
tout serait déjà joué dans les sondages
écrit-il
l'heure n'est pas à cacher le poing et
la rose mais a affirmé nos idées nos
convictions nos combats face aux
nouveaux réactionnaires
enfin un mot sur la réforme territoriale
on en sait un peu plus sur les futures
compétences des prochains conseillers
départementaux
oui puisque cet après midi l'assemblée
nationale a voté en première lecture la
nouvelle répartition des compétences
alors le département garde les collèges
et la voirie mais il n'aura plus la
compétence générale le transport
scolaire sera transférée aux régions et
l'eau et l'assainissement reviendront
aux intercommunalités et prochain
journal de campagne demain dans cette
édition